and I so fearful and I still I don't
want to go on auditions
I don't do anything I I don't go on
auditions anymore what do you mean you
get him though no why
I don't know you have an agent
yeah indeed you call me hey where's
auditions yeah I tell him man's like hey
what's what's going on right like
nothing okay but did you audition for
SNL every oh yeah I have an SNL story
you wanna hear yeah yeah because I just
want to say before you even get into it
is that uh I mean obviously I'm from the
sketch world yeah oh yeah nah eight
years on the sketch I know a lot of I
know you know I knew I know a lot of
people yeah yeah I've been in the game
and not I've met the bed not that but um
I'm slipping
yeah but I've seen you know I know great
impressionist I know Frank Caliendo well
I know uh people like that and but I
really believe that you're one of the
best
well there's your Trump is so good
you're Caitlyn Jenner is so good so
funny but so go to SNL go ahead so you
know as a kid as a dream mind to ENSO
now yeah most lot of kids and it took me
I made a cat ape of impressions I sent
it in and then they flew me out to New
York to like do the test where you
actually get miked and you go on the
stage and everybody heard about yeah and
I was very nervous I mean out of all the
things you've done the most it was the
10 top so I'm already like pretty peaked
out and I'm in a hotel room for two days
by myself running my six minutes
obsessively which is bad dis bad yeah
I'm trying to get it correct which is
not the right mindset but anyway I get
there and there's 30 of us auditioning
and it was like John Mulaney Nick Kroll
like very good people and it was 30 of
us my god and imagine yeah and I was
just like okay I just don't want to go
first
yeah yeah I don't I don't play pretty
god but I decided to yeah
first yeah so there he goes alright
first gonna be Kyle Dunnigan
oh my god and I was like and then I did
this whole thing up you know what just
do just go first
it's gonna be great trying to talk to
myself yeah yeah so then I go in like
this dress room there miking me up but I
feel like Who I am I am very very
nervous and I literally like close the
door on the producer like yeah I'm just
in the mirror like you can do this man
but I'm like so then like I'm walking
with the producer and the sound guy you
know whatever the camera guys like with
me and I feel like I mean walk to the
gallows Wow imagine that you are going
to die head chopped
Wow feeling I'm literally trembling and
so the the guy goes all right I'm gonna
count you in 3 2 1 then you go write
your stuff yeah 1 then you go right in
yourself and that is in my mind like 3 2
money away from being a funny person
just okay I walk out the end we're in
the Conan studio because the Olympics
were happening and the SNL studio was
taken for so the cameras in front but
everyone's to the left at a table like
Lorne Michaels and everybody yeah Walker
boy you reckon is aside from Lauren is
there Seth Meyers I of course at this
area and I was like okay there I don't
know who to do what say or look I don't
look at them and perform it looking up
something I look at the camera and then
I'm waiting for that to count me in any
nothing's happening so I'm just standing
there staring are you getting laughs at
this point just standing there oh no no
it's dead silent right my head would be
like do something right a little funny
dance or I was three two one going
you're stuck on to this like I'm
squeezing this puppy hard right and so
Lorne Michaels goes are you okay so then
I'm like
I learned a deeper level of panic at
this moment right are you sweating I'm
sweating and I'm trembling and I I i I
was like yeah yeah and then I go back to
the camera and nothing's happening
like did like that is it a that they do
or maybe so yeah so then I go and then
Lauren says this okay he goes oh wait no
first he goes hello that's he's at first
like say hi to us
oh hi and then I went back to the camera
and then nothing's happening and then he
goes are you okay and then I go yeah the
the guy said bro and I said like the guy
said he goes three so I'm like back
don't you
and I I don't have I can't get to my
facility to do impressions like I'm
doing like a Bill Maher it doesn't sound
like Bill Maher like I was too nervous
to even raw or oh my and then I got a
play I'd like a piano I put a piano I
took a song I couldn't play the piano
well like I just couldn't get to my
facility and and that was it but I you
know now what move was that the feeling
when you're trying on and you're walking
away dread what is the feeling dread
yeah so now you're leaving the side
stage looks like your dream died that's
the feeling dream yeah but look here's
the thing also yeah I mean that shows
high pressure it's live I need to be
able to perform in that kind of that's
what I do it so I mean really why they
ready that's why they do it yeah they
like the instagrams of I I'm not nervous
I'm in I'm at my home right dude but in
many would weird in a weird way though
that too is a way into people's psyche
he's doing it the way you're doing oh oh
yeah yeah I feel like you know because
I'm one of those performers that I can't
perform really to my full you know
ability with that much pressure yeah I
need to feel like like when I was
shooting this show because
I hadn't done a pilot or show in like
five years that in my head I'm like oh
this is it you're getting old yeah and
you have to deliver mm-hmm so when I was
driving to the tape because I would just
offer the job but and so I had some the
weird dinner with everybody yeah like no
one really said anything and then a
couple days later I'm driving to the
table read and my agent called me and he
goes just so you know this network and
the studio is all gonna be there so he's
listing off names yeah chanting now in
this you know Peter Roth Wow and all
these names he goes this is your
audition you have to kill it do you wish
she didn't say that yeah and I go what
do you mean and he goes this they've
never seen you to say these things these
despread so you cannot [ __ ] up a word I
don't think that I know but I'm like
okay right get more nervous yeah so I
hung up and then I remember shaking oh
right so he's saying it's not at that
level but still - in my world that was
pretty nerve-wracking in and of itself
raw edition well it's totally separate
from exactly everything out it's like
being good at shooting hoops but when it
comes to like the game you're three feet
tall like the poops farther away from
you yeah I'm getting nervous and you or
maybe when we're auditioning for the
team it's three feet tall but when the
real game rock we're LeBron James yeah
yeah yeah maybe that's how I feel about
myself is that during you know the
process of getting something I'm not
great me then when it's Showtime
yeah it's legitimately ready let's go
yeah I'm on yeah yeah and also when
you're doing a single camera you could
do it 20 30 times right right so it's
like you have that but my point is is
that it is you know but you know what we
still have to be able to like overcome
and I was we did a first table read and
I was terrible yeah and then they gave
me notes and they go just slow this part
down you know what we don't even know
what you're saying here
and I'm like I'm writing it all down on
my script yeah and then we go into what
time
[Laughter]
[Music]